نحن هنا في مخيم الشابوره في مدينه رفح
جنوبي قطاع غزه تعرض هذا المخيم من جديد
الى غارات جويه اسرائيليه ادت الى سقوط
مزيدا من الشهداء والجرحى وتدمير عشرات
البنايات السكنيه هذا المنزل كان على موعد
هذه الليله مع هذه الغاره الجويه العنيفه
التي ادت الى تدميره وتدمير منازل مجاوره
كما تشاهدون هنا امامكم في هذا المشهد هنا
نسير بحذر شديد نظرا لان المنازل ايله
للسقوط وهي منازل من الصفيح منازل متلاصقه
عندما تحدث غاره هنا او حتى يعني قصف
اسرائيلي كما حدث هذه الليله يلحق الدمار
والخراب الكبيرين بعدد كبير من المنازل
السكنيه المتلاصقه المتجاوره هنا في هذا
المكان ما الذي حدث معكم هنا في هذا
المكان والله كانت الساعه 3ه في الليل زي
هيك ما صحينا فجاه الا كل شيء فوق رؤوسنا
سمعنا ثلاث هو بالضبط اه وما طلعنا صرنا
نتفقد حالا تفقد البيت اللي تحت الركام
صرنا نطلع فيهم نتفقد الصغار اهم حاجه
طبعا بعدها طلعنا لقينا عند الجيران لقينا
عندك هنا ناس متصاوب وهنا شهداء وهنا كمان
شهداء هذه الاماكن بشكل عام مخضه مليانه
بالسكان والنازحين اللي اجوا من الشمال
واجوا من اجوا من خانيونس واجوا من
الانصراف اه والحمد لله طلع موجود في كان
شهداءنا وطلعنا بتته لسه برضه في لسه باقي
شهداء والحمد الله كم كم شهيد وكم اصابه
في هذا المكان هذا هين لحتى الان طلعوا
اربع شهداء اه غير الاصابات في عندك تعدد
كبير في الاصابات ربما تستدير الكاميرا في
هذه اللحظات لتنقل لكم المشاهد هنا الحيه
في هذا المكان وحجم الخراب والدمار
الكبيرين هذه منازل للاجئين ربما بنيت قبل
اكثر من 60 او 70 عاما وهي الان تدمر بفعل
هذه الغارات وكان السكان يعيشون نكبه
جديده بفعل هذه الحرب التي لم تبقي ولم
تضر ولم تترك شيئا هنا الا واتت
عليه تشكل هذه الحرب على قطاع غزه نكبه
جديده بالنسبه لسكان هذه المخيمات فهم على
امل منذ عام 48 بالعوده الى ديارهم لكن
هذه الغراه تحاول ان تبدد هذا الحلم هان
الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه رفح